[Música]
y
marruecos es el segundo país de áfrica
con más casos acumulados de kobe 19
habiendo superado los 120 mil en el país
se registran alrededor de 2000 casos
diarios pero es importante tener en
cuenta que sigue siendo mayor el número
de pacientes dados de alta y también que
la tasa de mortalidad a causa del virus
aquí en marruecos es del 18 por ciento
muy baja en relación a la media
continental y también a otras partes del
mundo aún así se sigue manteniendo
vigente el estado de emergencia
sanitaria decretado hace 7 meses por una
parte sigue habiendo restricciones de
movilidad y otras actividades en grandes
zonas del país y por otra parte y entre
cierta desconfianza se intenta reactivar
el turismo se han reabierto las
fronteras a los turistas exentos de
visados y es que la crisis económica ha
golpeado fuertemente el país según
últimos datos oficiales en el segundo
trimestre del año se han perdido casi
600 mil empleos y eso sin contemplar la
incontable cantidad de puestos de
trabajo de la economía informal
[Música]
sudáfrica se prepara para reabrir el
espacio aéreo el anuncio presidencial
sin embargo indicó que esto se limitaría
a ciertos países específicos y
seguramente se limitarán a países del
continente africano y esta apertura
indica la casi reactivación total de las
actividades en sudáfrica aunque se
mantiene todavía el toque de queda desde
la medianoche su aplicación en los
países más afectados por la pandemia
aunque su tasa de recuperación actual es
del 90 por ciento y la promedia de
apenas 1.000 casos diarios en las
últimas semanas estamos aquí frente al
suntuoso estadio de ciudad del cabo
donde los últimos meses cientos de
pasajeros han venido a abordar vuelos de
repatriación buscando volver a esos
países y salir de sudáfrica durante los
meses de pandemia y durante el pico de
esta epidemia aquí en el país pero
adicional el virus del cobi 19 sudáfrica
se enfrenta a lo que internamente llaman
el virus de la corrupción se trata de
malos manejos de fondos desde altos
niveles del gobierno que el mismo
presidente rama posa ha reconocido era
un fondos que estaban destinados a la
compra de equipos de protección personal
así como ayudas sociales y esto ha
socavado profundamente la confianza que
la población tenía en el gobierno que en
las primeras etapas de la pandemia logró
poner métodos muy efectivos para frenar
los contagios
[Música]
es el 11 de marzo que el primer caso del
juego
firmado aquí en costa de marfil desde
esa fecha aproximadamente 20.000
personas
infectadas con el virus casi tantas
personas se han curado hoy en el día hay
menos de 400 casos activos según el
gobierno desde el convencimiento de la
crisis sanitaria se han producido 120
muertes con el jueves 19 pondrá mente a
los catastróficos pronósticos de la onu
sobre el número de muertes en áfrica
costa de márfil vayan con un pago número
de muertes impares son de otros países
occidentales los expertos creen que hay
varios factores que explican esto unos
de ellos puede ser la rápida reacción
del gobierno marfileño según la ms costa
de márfil representa menos del 2 por
ciento de los casos de políticas
[Música]